hey everybody Chad here from real-life
English and learn English with tv-series
today we have another amazing lesson for
you guys based on the TV show The Big
Bang Theory so to really get the most
out of this lesson
I highly recommend you download the
power lesson which is a more extensive
guide of all the vocabulary
pronunciation and some cultural
references too so download that and
watch this awesome lesson with the Big
Bang Theory oh yeah
hey Sheldon what are you doing here this
is a restaurant it's lunchtime I would
think as a waitress you'd be familiar
with the paradigm is Leonard coming no I
believe Leonard is waiting for you to
come crawling back to him and apologize
yeah well that's not gonna happen I
assumed that would be your attitude
hence my true purpose in coming here
which is I want you to crawl back to him
and apologize
I'm busy excuse me miss I'd like to
order lunch
fine what do you want I have a few
questions first I noticed that you offer
soup and a half sandwich yes where
exactly does the half sandwich come from
are you giving me half of someone else's
sandwich
do I have to wait for someone else in
the restaurant to order the other half
no no show them they just make a half
sandwich you can't make a half sandwich
if it's not half of a whole sandwich
it's just a small sandwich okay fine
it's soup and a small sandwich is that
what you want no of course not I'll have
my usual great what aren't you going to
ask me if I want a beverage don't you
usually get lemonade yeah you want
lemonade yeah anything else yes I want
you to apologize to Len
I would think as a waitress she'd be
familiar with the paradigm and I would
think as a waitress she'd be familiar
with the paradigm I believe Leonard is
waiting for you to come crawling back to
him and apologize yeah well that's not
gonna happen
I assumed that would be your attitude
hence my true purpose in coming I
assumed that would be your attitude
hence my true purpose in coming you
can't make a half sandwich if there's
not half of a whole sandwich it's just a
small sandwich what aren't you going to
ask me if I want a beverage what are you
doing here what are you doing here
are you doing here what are you doing
here are you doing here
this is a restaurant this is arrest from
this is arrest from this is a restaurant
this is arrest from yeah well that's not
gonna happen
yeah well that's not gonna happen yeah
well that's not gonna happen yeah well
that's not gonna happen yeah well that's
not gonna happen what do you want what
do you want what do you want what do you
want what do you want I have a few
questions I have a few questions I have
a few questions I have a few questions I
have a few questions are you giving me
half of someone else's sandwich are you
giving me half of someone else's
sandwich are you giving me half of
someone else's sandwich are you giving
me half of someone else's sandwich is
that what you want is that what you are
is that what you want is that what you
want is that what you are aren't you
going to ask me if I want a beverage
aren't you going to ask me if I want a
beverage aren't you going to ask me if I
want a beverage aren't you going to ask
me if I want a beverage aren't you going
to ask me if I want a beverage you want
lemonade you want lemonade you want
lemonade you want lemonade
hey Sheldon what are you doing here this
is a restaurant it's lunchtime excuse me
miss I'd like to order lunch
hey Sheldon what are you doing here this
is a restaurant it's lunchtime I would
think as a waitress she'd be familiar
with the paradigm is Leonard coming no I
believe Leonard is waiting for you to
come crawling back to him and apologize
yeah well that's not gonna happen I
assumed that would be your attitude hits
my true purpose in coming here which is
I want you to crawl back to him and
apologize I'm busy
excuse me miss I'd like to order lunch
fine what do you want I have a few
questions first I noticed that you offer
soup and a half sandwich yes where
exactly does the half sandwich come from
are you giving me half of someone else's
sandwich
do I have to wait for someone else in
the restaurant to order the other half
no no Sheldon they just make a half
sandwich you can't make a half sandwich
if it's not half of a whole sandwich
it's just a small sandwich okay fine
it's soup and a small sandwich is that
what you want no of course not I'll have
my usual great what aren't you going to
ask me if I want a beverage don't you
usually get lemonade yeah you want
lemonade yeah anything else yes I want
you to apologize to way